all right as biden struggles america's
enemies are sadly becoming emboldened
vladimir putin is now publicly taunting
and threatening the united states
china's dictator right now is hurling a
few violent threats of his own he
doesn't want to be left out
and the ccp will probably never take
responsibility for the virus they
unleashed upon the world
according to one new report a top
researcher at the muhan institute of
virology
has deep ties to china's military so
what does this mean for the united
states and what can we do to hold the
malignant communist party of china
accountable
joining me now with more is arkansas
senator tom cotton senator thanks a lot
for joining me really appreciate it
good to be on with you dan so senator
you were one of the voices
that were you were attacked grotesquely
attacked for speaking truth early on and
asking just basic questions
hey there's a lab in wuhan that studies
coronaviruses we have a
coronavirus outbreak that lab has had
safety problems in the past
um you know as a pretty smart guy you
said maybe we should ask some questions
about this
and you were brutally attacked and you
know i know you're not one of these
shouting fraud guys but
it's got to feel good to be right and to
put them on their heels a little bit the
left and the media i mean they look like
idiots now
then you know i wish i'd been wrong
obviously uh given all that
americans have lost over the last 18
months from this pandemic but
it didn't really take a lot of
intelligence last year to say gosh this
virus emerged from wuhan a city larger
than new york
right down the street from that lab
where they researched viruses and the
lady that runs those labs
is literally nicknamed the bat lady
maybe we should take a look at them
i'm glad to see that nbc news is finally
reporting to its viewers
that that lab has deep ties to the
chinese communist party's
military if you're watching fox 18
months ago
and ever since you would know that there
is no distinction in china
between the party and the state and the
military and
supposedly private institutions like
government research institutions or
companies or anything else the party
controls everything
and the military is the arm of the
communist party in china
you know senator i i had a former dni
john ratcliffe on my show last week and
i asked him this question i'll ask you
it
it just sadly it feels like we're losing
here i mean china's infiltrated
hollywood
our sports industry we have technology
takeovers
you know we've had government
procurement issues in china intellectual
property theft
you know we have taiwan and being
threatened we have hong kong
right now in the midst of a takeover
right in front of our faces
i mean what can we do is there any way
to expand kind of a magnitsky type thing
where we can sanction some of their
diplomats and their kids i mean the one
thing they want to do is be able to
visit america
but doesn't it listen i'm a patriot like
you
but we've got to be candid doesn't it
feel like we're taking a
kick in the cajones here man we got to
fight back
yeah dan uh as you say politicians in
both parties for many decades
uh put china's interest ahead of so many
americans interests whether it's our
factory workers
or our troopers who are stationed in the
western pacific some of the missionaries
we had going to china
say nothing what they do to their own
people in places like hong kong
or northwest china where they're
committing genocide against ethnic and
religious minorities
right but we need to remember that china
needs us a lot more than we need them we
can buy our t-shirts and sneakers from
another country but where are they going
to sell theirs
so we can slap more tariffs on them as
you say we can take away visas from
chinese communist officials and their
kids so they don't come here and take
spots in our universities it should be
for american kids
we can revoke their permanent most
favored nation status so they don't get
that beneficial trade status but rather
congress and the president have to
decide every year whether we'll extend
it for one more year
those are all ways that we can make
china pay
not just for unleashing this plague on
the world
but also for decades of lying and
cheating
and stealing it is time to lower the
boom
on china yeah and it seems senator
like the only country doing it right now
is australia australia has taken a
pretty muscular stand
um and it seems like we're just taking
back the tape but just i want to move on
quickly to russia because that's
important too
you're obviously well versed in foreign
policy you know what an embarrassment
right that that president biden stops a
pipeline here the keystone pipeline
costs americans 11 000 jobs and cost us
domestic energy security
but then he gives vladimir putin a free
pass
to build a pipeline to enrich themselves
straight to germany
when the trump administration tried to
stop this because of the transit fees
that they would have bypassed i mean
this is i don't understand how democrats
up on the hill with you
see that as being fair block a pipeline
here but give it to russia
yeah it's crazy dan um that we would end
a pipeline here that's going to create
thousands of high-paying american jobs
it's going to provide more energy
security to the united states and our
ally canada to the north
well joe biden allows that pipeline to
be built from russia to germany
to more deeply hook western europe on
russian
gas and to prevent americans from
exporting our gas to western europe when
we could create even more jobs here and
let's not forget
a third pipeline in this tale of three
pipelines dan it was
russian criminals that hacked into the
colonial pipeline that caused gas lines
all across the eastern united states and
joe biden's
anemic response to them did nothing to
teach vladimir putin a lesson that he
cannot continue to harbor
these cyber criminals who continue to to
attack
america's critical infrastructure like
gas pipelines or
meat processing plants the only thing
vladimir putin is learning over the last
six months
is that uncle sam is wearing a kick me
sign
with joe biden in the white house you
know senator that's a great way to sum
up these dreadful last six months those
three pipelines that tells the whole
story
i'm out of time unfortunately thanks a
lot for joining us senator tom cotton
really appreciate it
thank you dan happy independence day to
everyone hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else